yeah hello and welcome to this video
playing Julian Hodgson and tech GM let's
seem I can do better now my positions
against him are usually good the results
not so much I am right he placed them he
plays a modern defense with c6 and yeah
this has a pretty dodgy reputation but
I'm not an e4 player II five is good for
why but it's extremely complicated and I
don't know exactly why it is better for
wine 594 takes match if I have something
like that this variation here is some is
also um also cost a little bit not as
testing yeah so fairly fairly solid
position classical classical stuff so
get pieces out try to
um see if I can play for for small
things in this position it's not going
to be easy here to play for anything
substantial
yeah but I think given the choice I'd
rather be white um okay what to do here
it's going to play 927 next I would like
to play 95 but I think he just has F 692
to see voice also making some sense but
that blunders the bishop
hmm i wonder if Bishop g5 was actually
that clever I was thinking that kind of
provoking e6 would be something that
helps me but seems that the dumb
drilling we are just 97 um yeah I would
like to play for the square it's
probably difficult we have at the bishop
is not doing anything on on g5 so going
to get into g3 ty wants me he wants a
410 ought we to take interesting
yeah came across my ID here anyway
maybe five now hmm I should have played
Bishop g3 first maybe if if I've could
be could be good now okay so let's take
here yeah I'm putting pretty equal ish
can I do something night to d6 that
doesn't really do much just do much at
all
i 94 m oh I completely forgot about this
idea who I was I was playing wanted to
play Knight B 3 c1 g3 but this is
probably not going to work that's not
good that's not good
that info I want to play 95 now hope
that works
and I totally relied on that that I
would bring the night to d3 and then
it's just totally equal let's see you
for this puzzle 92o missing simple
tactics yeah our cake takes a strike
Texas is a tactics is a big word for 92
no okay okay
check some not much fun to defend this
position okay but it's a it is the wrong
bishop so I just have to treat bishop
and f pawn against ucf porn so time
morning this is should be doable why do
I go back that far it looks weird maybe
we should eat seven actually make it
difficult time to move that let make
some sense
hurtling mate but it's not going to
happen check okay that's actually
interesting
they I defended this badly I really did
I shouldn't have allowed that I am I'm
just losing I'm such an idiot yeah this
wasn't he can I told you draw this
position should never happen really
never okay I'm a [ __ ] really quite
resigned or is it really a winning idea
with their for Kenneth maybe I cannot
prevent it actually mean hmm I know can
I prevent it he it's losing at this idea
is probably only good but if I go here
I'm just cannot move the king
that's tough to say if with some
precision I'm drawing this on not really
not the engine basically says it's draw
but not trusting this but trusting this
so easily but this this looks it looks
like a draw already there probably is a
draw ah not a good game really I
shouldn't should get into trouble in the
first place but just draw the ending
part yet it's not always not not that
easy yeah kind of a big game right never
had anything it was equal ish and then I
drifted into the bad ending which I lost
probably shouldn't but it's not fun to
play of course yeah the opening is that
this is always hurts a little bit you
know the opponent is playing something
which is bad but you don't quite know
where I'm how to review it I know that's
good for Wyatt but I don't know exactly
how you know c5 this is a various very
concrete line which has put this out of
business I think yet the engine is I'm
not sure the engine is able to find it
like just right away and I'm not saying
that white wins or anything but I think
this is the reason why the black setup
is not played simply ok guys thanks for
watching